mon camarade jean-Pierre Sueur vous
aurait exposé la position du groupe
socialiste sur les grandes lignes du
texte je me concentrerai pour ma part
sur l'article 7 qui impose au cabinet
conseil travaillant pour l'état de bien
vouloir s'il vous plaît employer la
langue française dans les échanges avec
l'administration et dans la rédaction de
leur document cet article est issu d'une
des recommandations de cette commission
d'enquête où j'ai siégé avec plaisir et
grâce à laquelle nous avons pu mesurer
ce qui se passe dans les coulisses de
ces marchés publics ou diapositives
après diapositive les cabinets offrent
les solutions adéquates que ne saurait
trouver par elle-même les
administrations
j'aurais pu dire pour me faire mieux
comprendre de l'écosystème qui nous
occupe et qui nous écoutent peut-être
que j'ai fait partie du board de la
commission qui a mesuré behindacine
comment slide après slide les
consultants junior et seniors d'un même
practice font des propales pour offrir
les bons feedbacks et les killer à leur
prospect public
chers collègues si comme moi vous
n'entendez rien à ce sabir rassurez-vous
la commission d'enquête je remercie
Eliane assassy à annexer au rapport un
glossaire du vocabulaire dont les
cabinets conseils inondent leurs clients
mais inquiétez-vous et inquiétons-nous
de la situation qui a rendu ce glossaire
malheureusement indispensable lors de
son audition le PDG de la Poste a
déclaré que le recours trop systématique
au cabinet faisait courir le risque je
cite d'un nouveau conformisme ce
conformisme passe par la langue il
conduit un appauvrissement de la pensée
ce globish qui n'est même pas de
l'anglais est en fait un instrument de
formateur nombreux sont les
fonctionnaires et les citoyens ils l'ont
dit à en concevoir une souffrance
certaine
la France a un rapport particulier à la
puissance publique et à l'administration
qui lui est propre Villers-Cotterêts
n'est pas Wall Street et ce rapport
entre la France et son administration ne
peut être appréhendé par les seules
cadres de pensée ou traite atlantique
ceci correspondent parfaitement à la
culture anglo-saxonne et c'est une
grande culture mais ce n'est pas la
nôtre et elle ne permet pas de
développer souverainement notre propre
vision de l'action publique la légère
modification de la loi tout bon
proposait dans ce texte ne saurait être
résumé à une approche pas séiste
consistant à regretter le bon vieux
temps de l'imparfait du subjonctif ou de
la marine à voile ce n'est pas non plus
la recherche d'une langue pure car une
langue figée est une langue finie c'est
un fantasme morbide que je laisse aux
réactionnaires on doit accepter
l'intégration et même avec gourmandise
de mots étrangers ou nouveaux lorsqu'ils
recouvre mieux que n'importe quel autre
une réalité que notre langue parfois ne
décrit pas en revanche lorsque le mot
existe en français et surtout j'arrive
au point essentiel lorsqu'il est
parfaitement entendu de tous les
citoyens il doit être employé pour que
les gens se comprennent entre eux c'est
un impératif démocratique autant qu'un
refus de l'entre-soi une récente étude
du creddock sur le sujet rappelle je
cite cette attachement magnifique à la
langue qui se décline à travers
l'expression de la nécessité de service
public exemplaires sur le sujet c'est ce
qu'exprime l'article 7 de la présente
proposition de loi dans un contexte où
les gouvernements de longue date ne
respectent ni la loi tout bon ni des
dispositions réglementaires prises en
application de celle-ci ni les
circulaires primo ministériels qui
s'imposent à l'administration les tchuss
France French tech business France
France Connect frenching pack start-up
nation bottom up et autres cluster sont
autant d'agressions creusant le fossé
entre le peuple et ses représentants il
faut en avoir conscience quand on est
payé par le contribuable on le sert dans
sa langue ça vaut pour l'administration
comme pour ses dirigeants comme pour ses
prestataires en février dernier
l'Académie française
publie un rapport sous-titré pour que
les institutions françaises parlent
français on en est rendu là tout de même
en juin dernier le ministre québécois la
langue française en visite à Paris nous
invitait avec émotion à ne pas laisser
son gouvernement seul dans la bataille
nous devons les entendre nous avons une
occasion rare de renforcer utilement la
loi tout bon monsieur le ministre
saisissons là d'aucun inscrirez sur leur
slide de conclusion que c'est Nao en
never pour réaffirmer les principes
linguistiques mais avec l'audace dont
nous savons faire preuve au Sénat et sur
tous les bancs et beaucoup plus
clairement nous pouvons dire que c'est
maintenant ou jamais je vous remercie
[Musique]